prends ton vélo mange ta pizza avec son
carton éteint la lumière montre-moi ton
côté sombre ces petits gestes qu'on nous
dit de faire pour le climat ça a
vraiment un impact sur notre bilan
carbone au final ou alors c'est
dérisoires et ils font ça pour instaurer
une dictature verte et nous occuper
pendant qu'il monte à un complot mondial
satanique de porteur de sandales
chaussettes c'est une question que je me
pose depuis un moment déjà oui tel quel
question là précisément et j'ai décidé
d'enfin y apporter une réponse une fois
n'est pas coutume cette vidéo est
réalisée en partenariat avec Lotus
devenir influenceuse PQ je vous ai pas
l'imaginer ils l'ont fait moralité
croisait en vos rêves or donc pourquoi
Lotus outre parce que le dérèglement
climatique c'est caca
et bien parce qu'il va nous faire
pousser une conscience environnementale
ils nous ont donc concocté des petits
défis éco-responsables à réaliser dans
votre quotidien et dans le mien car je
vais les tester pour votre plus grand
plaisir vous connaissez bien ma
conscience écologique d'ailleurs là je
tourne cette vidéo en 4K et du coup je
me suis dit que c'était l'occasion rêvée
de voir si ça marchait vraiment cette
rhétorique des petits gestes alors bien
sûr outre ce très léger conflit
d'intérêt du fait que c'est lotus qui
régale je fais cette vidéo avec tout
indépendance éditoriale et la rigueur et
le sérieux qui me caractérise alors
éteignez moi ce SUV recracher cette côte
d'Angus et prenez des notes sur du
papier recycle et bien sûr alors tout
d'abord c'est quoi le problème et bien
pour paraphraser une grande ponceuse du
21e siècle c'est nous bonjour nous
sommes le problème c'est nous le
problème c'est qu'on aimait trop de CO2
avec nos activités de gens qui font des
choses comme manger se déplacer se
chauffer regarder des vidéos de 10
heures d'aquarium aujourd'hui un
Français émet en moyenne autour de 9
tonnes équivalence CO2 chaque année
c'est beaucoup c'est pas beaucoup c'est
beaucoup c'est pas beaucoup c'est
beaucoup bien plus que la moyenne
mondiale qui s'élève à 6h30 par habitant
donc vous me voyez venir faut qu'on se
mette au régime on doit réduire le plus
vite et le plus fort possible nos
émissions et je parle pas de TPMP même
si c'est dans ce contexte que la France
s'est réveillé un matin et s'est engagée
à la neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 un
peu comme vous au lendemain de cuite qui
vous dites je boirai plus jamais et ben
là le pays tout entier c'est 17 fois
c'est décidé j'aimais pas plus de gaz à
effet de serre que je n'en absorbe d'ici
30 ans mais pour tenir un tel objectif
il faut qu'on se sert la ceinture dès
maintenant c'est un sacré défi il va
falloir bigment modifier nos habitudes
de consommation enfin les vôtres parce
que les miennes sont déjà exemplaires
c'est des LED
c'est parti pour les défis Lotus on
commence dans la salle de bain premier
défi remplacer votre gel douche par du
savon solide ça fait toujours ça de
déchets économisés
sinon vous pouvez aussi décider de ne
plus vous laver du tout et là vous aurez
une vraie tête d'écolo nouveau défi
faire pipi sous la douche c'est pas très
pratique mais c'est un coup de main à
prendre
renforcer
les belles économies de plastique
en parlant de lotus adopter l'innovation
Lotus sans tube un rouleau de PQ sans
carton au milieu c'est possible grâce à
Lotus centuple
[Musique]
même que si en octet tous pour du papier
toilette Lotus sans tube on éviterait
11954 tonnes de cartons par an soit le
poids de 398 baleines à bosse en plus
les rouleaux sont deux fois plus longs
car rouleau classique vous pouvez donc
regarder deux fois plus de vidéos sur le
trône avant d'arriver à court de papier
merci lotus à ce jeu certains petits
gestes pèsent plus lourd que d'autres
soit balance environnementale une bonne
résolution c'est de moins consommer en
général du coup moins d'impact sur le
climat sauf le papier toilette ça vous
pouvez en acheter plein on peut aussi
consommer mieux l'une des manières les
plus efficaces de le faire c'est de
manger moins de viande et de produits
laitiers des chercheurs ont calculé en
2019 que l'élevage occupait 83% de
notaire agricoles et étaient responsable
à lui seul de 60% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre liées à l'agriculture
j'ai oublié de respirer au début de soi
16% des émissions globales le journal
britannique de Golden a même échangé
avec l'auteur principal de l'étude qui
leur a dit tout de go qu'est son avis
adoptait un régime vegan c'était la
meilleure façon de réduire notre impact
sur la planète pas seulement vis-à-vis
des gaz à effet de serre mais pour la
signification l'eutrophisation l'US et
l'utilisation de l'eau moralité
verdissez votre assiette et côté bilan
carbone ça vous ferez économiser la
modique somme de 0,8 tonnes par an soit
4 fois plus que le recyclage de vos
déchets et 8 fois plus que le fait de
changer vos ampoules pour des bases
conso l'idée étant bien sûr de pas
choisir l'un ou l'autre tous les petits
riens comptent prochain défi dans la
cuisine adopter les co- cuisson si vous
voulez économiser 10% d'électricité
éteignez le four avant que le plat ne
soit tout à fait cuit sur vos casseroles
utilisez un couvercle pour faire
bouillir votre eau plus vite et éteignez
le feu avant que les pâtes ne soient
cuites vous verrez la différence sur
votre facture d'énergie mais pas dans
l'assiette
supprimer 200 g de viande par semaine
trop fastoche pour votre hydratation
pensez à la gourde pas votre sœur bien
qu'elle puisse contenir une quarantaine
de litres d'eau à elle seule ce qui
n'est pas négligeable mais c'est moins
pratique pour s'hydrater en pleine rue
et oui car une gourde ça vous permet
d'utiliser moins de bouteilles en
plastique et à l'échelle de la France
une semaine sans bouteilles en plastique
ferait économiser près de 5000 tonnes de
plastique soit le poids de plus de 7
millions d'oeufs de poules imaginées la
taille de l'omelette
dans la série des gestes qui comptent le
plus à part la suprématie des légumes
d'autres chercheurs invitent aussi à se
passer d'une voiture moins 2 tonnes 4 de
CO2 chaque année évitez de prendre
l'avion moins une tonne 6 par vol
transatlantique ou encore avoir moins
d'enfants alors cette dernière idée a
causée quelques mots on n'aime pas trop
quand on nous dicte le nombre d'enfants
qu'on doit avoir mon rhum steak frites
du Midi d'accord je veux bien rogner
mais mes rêves de fonder une famille bon
là tu pousses le bouchon un peu trop
loin Mao certes avoir moins d'enfants
forcément ça va réduire notre empreinte
environnementale ça c'est mathématique
il y a d'ailleurs de plus en plus de
jeunes qui sont à ne pas avoir de
progéniture pour cette raison là et je
salue leur dévouement ou alors c'est
parce qu'ils sont pas hyper Jojo à
l'idée de faire naître des êtres
directement dans les flammes de l'enfer
en 2021 des chercheurs ont réalisé un
sondage auprès de 10 000 jeunes dans 10
pays et 39% d'entre eux hésitaient à
avoir des enfants un jour à cause du
changement climatique en France en
particulier ils étaient 37% bon mais du
coup si des prêts mais ils font plus de
gosse c'est tout bénef ça va diminuer
leur empreinte carbone ils
économiseraient entre 7,8 et 58 tonnes
de CO2 par an pendant 80 ans oui c'est
une grande fourchette tous les
chercheurs sont pas d'accord entre eux
alors oui en rognant sur notre
descendance on diminue sans doute notre
de frein de carbone et pas que
d'ailleurs mais d'un autre côté l'impact
qu'on a à dire adieu à Molas et
côtelettes les filles que je n'ai jamais
eu et jamais qu'à long terme l'effet
n'est pas mesurable tout de suite on
fait un cadeau à la génération suivante
donc avoir moins d'enfants c'est
chouette et oui ça fera très
probablement du bien à la planète et à
vos oreilles mais comme disait François
Hollande c'est maintenant qu'on veut du
changement pardy alors que vous décidiez
d'avoir des mioches ou pas ça vous
regarde et un peu moi aussi vu que c'est
eux qui paieront ma retraite mais de
toute façon ça ne remplace pas de faire
des efforts en parallèle alors reposez
moi ce faux-filet prochain challenge
côté fripes préférez le vintage
pour laver vos vêtements utilisez le
programme Umberto Eco du lave-linge pour
consommer moins d'eau et gratter 15 à
50% d'électricité si vous l'avez à froid
pareil avec le lave-vaisselle Umberto
vous permet d'économiser jusqu'à 45%
d'électricité par cycle merci à lui
mais c'est pas tout vous pouvez aussi
voter avec le portefeuille en consommant
de préférence des produits à faible
émission de cette manière vous forcez
les industriels à adopter une démarche
plus éco-responsable vous pouvez aussi
vérifier que vous n'avez pas confié vos
économies à une banque qui finance les
énergies fossiles par exemple parlez de
ces petits riens autour de vous pour que
vos proches vos amis votre famille
sachent comment réduire efficacement
leur empreinte carbone autre option
faire un don à une association de
défense de l'environnement alors pas
n'importe laquelle à vous de mener votre
enquête en amont pour savoir ce qui
fabrique vraiment ou ira votre argent et
s'ils font bien leur travail pour vous y
aider il y a des organisations
indépendantes qui classent les
associations en fonction de leur
bénéfiques robustesse je vous laisse
chercher tout ça une autre façon de vous
engager ça peut être aussi de choisir un
métier qui fasse avancer le schmilblick
par exemple qui nous aide à sensibiliser
et éduquer les populations à ces
questions ou bien à trouver des
solutions ou des filles qui nous restent
à résoudre devenaient ingénieur ou
architectes et construisait des villes
bac carbone ça passe aussi par le vote
et oui on l'oublie souvent celui-là
votez pour des représentants qui bah
déjà parlent d'environnement dans leur
programme on va pas placer la barre trop
donc oui les petits gestes individuels
ça marche peut-être pas tous mais en
tout cas on a pu voir lesquelles avec
plus d'impact mais ça ça marche à
condition qu'on s'y mette tous et qu'on
soit pas les seuls à le faire non parce
que c'est bien mignon de vous demander
de faire tout le boulot et de vous
coltiner les camps anxiété qui va avec
mais évidemment les efforts doivent être
aussi fournis par l'État les
collectivités et les entreprises
les petits riens dans le bureau
défis suivants supprimer une newsletter
non lui par mois en voilà un petit rien
auquel on ne pense pas forcément
débranchez ces appareils électriques
inutilisés et oui n'oubliez pas ou
encore éteignez vos appareils en veille
y compris votre box une box qui marche
24 heures sur 24 ça peut manger plus de
200 kWh soit la consommation d'un
lave-linge alors la nuit débranchez moi
tout ça vous voulez bien
après quelle est l'importance relative
de ces différentes contributions
individuelles versus collectives
difficile à évaluer certains chercheurs
vont vous dire les efforts individuels
c'est peanuts à côté du reste d'autres
au contraire vous diront que non
seulement c'est pas cacahuète du tout
d'autant plus que si vous voyez des gens
adopter un certain comportement autour
de vous vous allez avoir spontanément
envie de vous y mettre aussi donc ça
peut vite faire un effet boule de neige
allez voir la vidéo de file qui est
vachement bien mais en plus la recherche
en sciences humaines suggère que si les
gens modifient leur comportement ça peut
donner de l'élan pour faire évoluer tout
le système moi ce que j'en dis si vous
me demandez c'est que si les Nations
Unies pleines chercheurs et même le GIEC
invite à modifier nos habitudes alors
c'est qu'on peut avoir un impact quel
que soit l'ampleur ce sera toujours un
pas dans la bonne direction faire plus
de sobriété énergétique selon carbone 4
le cabinet de conseils confondé par
Jean-Marc Jankovic en appliquant des
mesures raisonnables sur notre
comportement on pourrait diminuer de 20%
notre bilan carbone ce qui est beaucoup
mais pas suffisant le reste d'après les
auteurs ne peut venir que d'une
impulsion politique et collective c'est
à dire modifier notre environnement
social technique et politique l'étude
elle-même a été débattue mais retenons
surtout la conclusion sur laquelle
s'accorde beaucoup d'experts les petits
gestes individuels oui mais c'est toute
la société l'industrie qu'il faut
repenser industrie qui est responsable à
elle seule de 17% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en France même si c'est
le secteur qui a le plus réduit ses
émissions ces 30 dernières années
d'ailleurs grâce au lotus centube Lotus
a réduit sa production de déchets de 59%
de plus leur technique de compression
des rouleaux à abaisser le nombre de
camions nécessaires à leur transport de
l'entrepôt au magasin réduisant leurs
émissions de CO2 de 5%
et vous quelles sont vos petits riens
qui changent tout moi je plante des
arbres
je recycle l'eau des cabinets pour me
laver les dents c'est pas l'inverse vous
êtes pas censé prendre l'eau de lavage
de vos dents pour mettre dans votre
chasse d'eau plutôt
ah mes petits gestes oh c'est ça
et parfois aussi un peu ça mais
essentiellement ça
au moins vous savez je reviens d'un pays
qui n'a pas la fibre donc ça fait
vraiment relativiser sur la justice
climatique
quoi
voilà maintenant vous savez quoi faire
pour réduire votre empreinte carbone et
vous réservez un avenir tout doux et
très résistant
et comme disait un proverbe basque tous
ensemble tous ensemble ouais
si vous voulez calculer votre empreinte
climatique et voir sur quel levier vous
pouvez jouer pour diminuer votre score
faites donc un tour sur le site nos
gestes climat le simulateur préféré des
Français juste après tractopelle
Simulator et ce sera notre dernier petit
rien du jour je finirai par vous donner
mon avis de comptoir en passant si vous
trouvez que tout ça ça fait un peu
beaucoup pour vous et vous avez
subitement du mal à respirer et vous
trouvez qu'on attend trop de choses de
vous alors que vous vous étiez juste
venu vous détendre en regardant YouTube
à la base dites-vous que personne
n'attend de vous un comportement
exemplaire moi-même je filme cette vidéo
en 4K mais un petit rien c'est déjà
mieux que rien merci d'être venu merci à
Lotus de m'avoir offert l'opportunité de
ma vie et du PQ jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours tout sera utilisé zéro gaspi
j'espère que ce partenariat vous aura
pas trop déserté je fais jamais ça
d'habitude mais là pas résister à
bientôt et n'hésitez pas à aller jeter
un œil au petit rien sur le site de
lotus
[Musique]